la première oeuvre
c'était un morceau de papier avec écrit
le week-end artistes pas c'est exact
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est exact le temps quoi des frais
comme ça parce qu'à l'époque g
vu comme ça à paris dans la situation de
l'art moderne et j'ai compris très vite
que la moderne était quelque chose qui
allait vers une extinction où chacun
pouvait en faire
et réussir à condition de prouver que
c'était plus en plus modernes comme ça
j'ai pensé alors qu'en mai dans louis 46
open ça suffisait tout ce que je fais
c'est de l'art puisque je suis un
artiste
oui à l'époque salue le succès mais 20
ans après c'est des tableaux qui sont
très recherchés en 77 plus tard
complètement retourné t'avais c'est la
phase de l'opération se faire coter
retourner la figuration
tu t'es mis à faire des nus des anges
oui ça alors c'est intéressant que
j'appelle retourné sa veste et comme eux
comme gainsbourg y compris même temps
c'est une connotation politique
oui il ya certains s'étaient vécu comme
un certain ronnie manche a été exclu du
groupe support surface en plus non non
je peux tu expliquer les autres qui sont
partis à la gare et berguois ceux qui
veulent notre milieu très apparent
trouve ça extrêmement
ouverte et libérale est en fait très
puritain et très très surveillée mais
qu'elle veut qu'ils passent de
l'abstraction et la figuration on le vit
toujours très mal oui je désire que tu
t'es mis à peindre un peu dans l'esprit
en fait tu te fais des ménines c'est là
que tu as fait la chaise et les lignes
homme j'ai fait des enjeux
ouais 79e plein des anges c'était ces
mots j'aime bien peint des sujets qui
apparaissent comme la chronique
c'est à dire qu'elle est que les
problèmes en fait ça démontrait le fait
que tout le monde ne fasse pas ce que tu
faisais c'est que les autres ça n'est
pas très bien en fait et finalement la
peinture abstraite c'était un peu pour
les feignants qui disait jeudi que
c'était suffisant pour occuper tout une
fille l'aventuré avec moi que c'est plus
facile de faire croire qu'on est pas
quand on fait des choses abstraites quoi
oui c'est à dire un mauvais tableau
abstrait c'était ici la voix m.aubry
tableaux figuratifs voit tout de suite
enfin toute façon c'est laisser là où tu
as eu tout et ps2 combite pure haine
avec ben non oui bien sûr et je sais pas
c'est la même si tu veux tu as d
des artistes comme ben ou plus rennes il
se sent les adeptes absolument définitif
de stagnation formelle ou deux
milite pour une répétition de la forme
pour toujours pareil ex terrapon moi ça
m'intéresse pas moi j'ai envie
d'utiliser les quarante ans autant de
vies que j'ai à faire des piqûres des
choses difficiles
j'ai envie de me coucher le soir en
pensant je vais pas y arriver le
lendemain matin afin d'aider des bus ou
des enjeux des fils ils apprennent des
enjeux des luttes de tout ça ouais ça
m'ennuierait déjà la part en plus par
exemple seulement duré d'arrivée
l'atelier de savoir qu'est-ce que des
peintres voilà six essais les choses
très simples comme ça en la phase 3 de
l'opération sécurité ni à la sculpture
marchands alors la phase iii c'est la
structure oui bien sûr parce que c'est
reparti le développement 2
normal et l'appropriation des matériaux
des aventures bastille qui m'intéresse
moi aujourd'hui de remplir ma vie avec
des formes des couleurs et de sons
biographie comme ça artistique et comme
j'ai trouvé que le bronze était un peu
pompeux un peu un peu morbide et de gp
c'est un côté très précis que doc la
statue en bronze une sacralisation comme
ça du matériau et tout est maître de la
peinture dessus c'est au contraire y
introduire quelque chose de très festif
très léger est influencé par qui par
picasso dans la phase ii du picasso
depuis
de bonification surtout mathis sont les
grandes figures de contemporanéité
et puis sur la sculpture de giacometti
giacometti ou quelques sculptures
picasso pour d'autres
il ya des mégalos c'est une addition
particulier des copiés alors écoute ses
tripes c'est très bizarre parce que ceux
de ma génération dénis complètement ma
démarche
mais beaucoup d'artistes plus jeunes
sont très intéressés à ce que je fais et
il ya le voir pour parler ceux qui
pressentent que quelque part l'arrêt
dans une espèce de cul de sac comme ça
et ils viennent un peu discuté avec moi
de ce qui pourrait arriver de ce qui
pourrait se passer de ce qu'il pourrait
faire etc
je n'ai quand même temps parce que
toutes les structures comme le jeu
commençait une sculpture ya trois ans
ouais elle n'est pas encore terminée
aujourd'hui il y en a que je peux faire
dans la journée
ah bon oui tu es vend cher puisque tokyo
dans la journée ouais malheureusement
cherche à savoir combien tu gagnes tu as
compris oui c'est classique et je vends
des sculptures 30000 de 30 mille francs
à un million de francs
c'est bien oui c'est bizarre notre
métier des fois on gagne
deux cent à trois cent mille francs par
jour puis deux fois plus rien cela dit
les musées d'art moderne c'est de la
merde moi ça fait tourner le système il
ya des crédits qu'il faut distribuer
avec ses terrasses mais le musée d'art
moderne on sait bien qu'il n'y ait pas
qui en est parce que
quoi ça sert est ce que tu dis toi c'est
qu'ils en apic après il faut les remplir
donc on met n'importe quoi toronto il
assuré mais c'est bien c'est bien c'est
mieux qui est ça qu on fasse la guerre
d'autres choses comme ça en même temps
c'est une chose de particulier à notre
culture
imaginez pas des musées d'art moderne en
iran doit se tenir deux le traitement de
peinture c'est quelque chose que de
particuliers l'occident temps que moi
j'avais 15 ans je suis rentrée dans une
école d'art il y avait une femme nue et
autour de la femme nue 30 élèves avec
une feuille blanche en train date et si
tu sais rien ce truc c'est bien ça qu
apprendre à poser des bombes c'est sûr
mais oui mais attends ça veut dire que
tu regardes une femme nue pendant 1h 2h
express des choses le corps d'une femme
pendant une heure ou deux et que tu la
touche pas fait d'études est à la peine
bon ça implique déjà si tu veux le
respect ou une distanciation que je
voudrais vous de sublimation de désir
sexuel
ouais ça évite de mettre le tchador par
exemple si on veut voir des trucs de toi
alors tu vois la galerie beaubourg way
we et les sculptures plus d'un mois
l'atelier où m
à peine de quoi ça sert la peinture ou
la sculpture de minutes ouais par
exemple la peinture ça sert à l'homme a
montré qu'il est un être singulier c'est
à dire qu'ils appuient qui fait ça c'est
tout a changé quand même là depuis les
tampons entre les papiers non oui parce
que j'ai connu tout ça ouais j'aurais
facile de 2,2 de faire encore des
tampons ou des trucs comme ça oui c'est
sûr ça vaut combien tampon là
aujourd'hui
quatre cent mille francs wes la
république et bodmer elle est bonne mais
récit devait rester une définition de
toiles en fonctionnaires ça serait quoi
alors bricout de louis cane de poivre et
légumes mais qu'est ce qu'on dirait
artiste peintre grève français et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10
tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce
bleu